what up space fam golson here from anime
uproar back at it again to discuss the
latest developments in the one piece
story the title of this chapter builds
up the hype
so much telling us that this is the
decisive battle between kaido and big
mom
versus luffy and the other supernova
while the last chapter set the stage for
the battle we're told it will intensify
this time and intensification
is what we want to see so make sure to
stay tuned for that
if you do enjoy one piece and want to
keep the reviews coming
channel the pirate king within and smash
that like button with no mercy
if you haven't joined the nakama right
now by hitting that subscribe button and
most importantly hit that notification
bell or you will miss future one piece
videos
and while you wait for the next intense
chapter to drop feel free to check out
my growing one piece playlist where i
have videos about the yonko
warlords supernova and much more link to
that
is in the description now without
further ado let's jump into it as i
alluded to chapter 1001
is called the decisive battle of
monsters on onigashima on the side of
the cover page
we're told that the stage is set at
onigashima and that the battle
intensifies
some people were disappointed by chapter
1000 because there was so much hype and
anticipation and it ended up setting up
the stage for this crazy battle rather
than giving us huge reveals or a new
gear or something like that i myself
liked it because it served to show how
far luffy has come and it reaffirmed
what the whole series is about
luffy and his unflinching desire to
become the pirate king
rather than being the climax of the arc
it set the stage for the climactic
decisive battle and from here on
out including in this chapter we'll be
getting more and more of the action
we've been so excited to see
so in a sense i feel like people should
be glad oda didn't rush the battle
or anything like that and now we can
actually continue to enjoy the exciting
roller coaster ride
up to the climax beyond the 1000th
chapter
which was great in its own right so we
have the hypest of battlefields here
after luffy just delivered a significant
blow to kaido
now we're going to find out how
significant it truly was
yonko kaido and big mom are shocked that
after how easily kaido beat luffy last
time
he has the gall to still say he's going
to become the pirate king but luffy is
unflinching and determined as ever
not affected in the least by the screams
of yonko kaido admits that the attack
damaged him
as the others are impressed by luffy's
advanced use of hockey
kid is shocked that a punch actually
damaged kaido as i've mentioned before
up to this point swords seem to be the
most effective against his near
invincible self
so a punch rattling him like this is
pretty epic to see killer says this
battle is not lost after all so luffy is
shining here even among
all of these supernova truly impressing
them and giving them hope in an
otherwise hopeless seeming mission to
defeat two yonko
that's the insane power of luffy both
physical but more importantly
psychological
interestingly enough law is on a
different page saying he's not gonna let
it slide this time
what's he talking about we'll soon find
out in the meantime it's so great to see
a calm luffy being contrasted to an out
of control
screaming big mom saying luffy doesn't
even understand what it means to be the
pirate king and that's something i
respect about luffy he doesn't overthink
things he just goes for what he wants
for what he's committed to why
philosophize about what it means
to be pirate king when you can be moving
towards the goal
it's a good lesson don't get bogged down
by overthinking just keep taking action
towards your goal
then we get an extremely hyped scene one
of my favorites in this chapter
kaido rattled briefly equates luffy to
the handful of people that can fight
against the yonko he sees luffy's epic
figure and
pictures five figures behind him odin
whitebeard
goldie roger captain rocks and shanks
then he asks are you implying that you
are just as great as they are
clearly kaido is reluctant to accept
that luffy is that great
and yet he can't help but associate
luffy with these five legendary figures
luffy gives off that energy and why
these five specifically notice big mom
isn't there along with many other very
strong figures like garp
it doesn't necessarily mean that these
guys are the 5 strongest characters in
one piece but it does suggest that kaido
views these 5
in his mind at least in a league of
their own and having
shanks in that group is so hype we know
that
shang somehow managed to get kaido to
turn around when kaido wanted to kill
whitebeard
and so seeing him here further suggests
that that was the result of shanks's
strength i don't think even kaido
would believe that he could take on two
of these figures together
so when he was faced with having to
fight shanks before fighting whitebeard
it was no brainer for him to retreat i
gotta give it to oda he is
so good at hyping up shanks and leaving
us wanting so much more from him
as soon as he physically appears again
in the story i have no doubt the
collective one-piece fanbase will go
absolutely crazy now we can move on but
let's just appreciate the fact that a
yonko
would already associate luffy in the
presence of such legendary company we
see kaido use thunderbagwa
again this kind of move took out luffy
last time
now we can see how far he's come luffy
uses advanced observation hockey
aka future sight to foresee the attack
but even with that he can't avoid it
completely he says kaido is too fast so
let's just appreciate for a second how
insanely fast kaido is
for the big buff guy he is so props have
to go to kaido for that but props also
have to go to luffy who clearly survives
the attack and is ready for battle this
time
unlike last time and i enjoy kaido's
reaction here
i like that he smiles and is glad to see
that luffy's putting up a decent fight
this time around
it's always more interesting this way
than when a villain remains rattled and
afraid
and as a yonko and the so-called
strongest creature in the world kaido
has to put up a respectable fight here i
want luffy to win
but it has to be believable and
satisfying paying respect to kaido's
yonko level power
then yonko number two big mom is about
to attack luffy with prometheus
but my man zorro comes in with kinemon's
foxfire style
and slices the giant ball of fire how
cool is it that luffy
and zorro have come to the point where
they're exchanging blows with two yonko
it doesn't get any more exciting than
this luffy is psyched to see kinemon's
attack while zoro says
it's his now you gotta respect his
willingness to adopt what works in his
style and make it his own
and it also represents how the fiery
wills of the scabbards are still with
them pushing them forward in this battle
even if they're not physically here it's
funny to me how
zoro has to remind luffy not to let his
guard down for a second because they're
fighting to yonko
and just as he says that it looks like
kaido snuck up on luffy and is gonna get
another devastating hit
on him luckily the other supernova are
finally coming into play here and
although i love dragon ball moments like
when super saiyan goku insists on
fighting frieza one on one
i also really appreciate stuff like this
in one piece where the characters
recognize how strong two yonko are and
they are okay with working together
in bigger numbers in order to try to
take them down they don't
need to win one on one for it to be a
victory that's where the pirate stuff
comes in and the importance of crewmates
and alliances in accordance with this
law uses shambles to transport luffy to
him
and this is by far the funniest moment
for me in this chapter
i said last chapter that clearly luffy
was portrayed as the captain and leader
because law followed his orders and sent
the red scabbards below
and i truly didn't think the matter
would come up again but law had the same
thought and knew exactly how it would
look so he starts telling luffy that he
was gonna
send them below anyways and that because
luffy told him to do the same before he
did it
it now looks like law obeyed luffy's
orders
it's so freaking funny the rivalry
between these three captains but i gotta
say getting upset about such superficial
things
is not pirate king energy luffy who
doesn't usually care what other people
think responds how does that even matter
which is a much more pirating energy
response
still i absolutely love this scene it's
very realistic and very funny
law was being bothered by this the whole
time to the point that when everyone was
impressed by luffy punching down a yonko
law could only think about how he
wouldn't let luffy's insult to his
reputation slide
it is noteworthy that law refuses to be
second or subordinate to luffy in
any capacity even if his response here
was not
very manly and then kidd gets in on it
in the most hilarious way
saying he also thought that law had
finally become straw hat's lackey which
only infuriates law more
then kid says it doesn't matter to him
if a scrub joins another scrub
this is the unofficial translation but i
do appreciate hearing an insult i
haven't heard since my elementary school
days
when scrub was the go-to insult i have
no idea what it actually means but it's
interesting seeing it pop up again
i also love the fact that oda makes the
time to bring these characters to life
with their social interactions
rather than just ramming through the
action oda does this brilliantly in
general and that's what makes us fall in
love with
and care about these characters not how
strong they are
i will point out that usually there is
one person in an interaction who is
clearly reacting less to the other
and that person is usually the one with
more power status and or control in that
particular social situation
and one of the recurring things about
luffy is he's usually the more
unfazed one here law is losing it and
luffy is pretty non-reactive by
comparison
he totally didn't give that command
about the red scabbards a second thought
and i previously mentioned how even the
yonko especially big mom were reacting
way more to luffy than he was reacting
to them
it doesn't mean luffy is physically
stronger but it does
show how even now he behaves like a king
even in the presence of two of the
strongest pirates in the world
of course this usually applies in more
serious situations and sometimes in
comedic situations luffy can
definitely overreact big mom goes on to
send three fireballs at them one apiece
here's a part that i look forward to the
official translation for
because i'm not gonna lie kind of
confused here with this translation
luffy appears to say okay
how about the first person who touches
that is the scrub meaning the fireballs
if that is what he says then they'd all
avoid the balls
but what actually happens is they play a
game of chicken where it seems like
whoever gets out of the way
is the loser and becomes the scrub and
kid concurs
that the game is pointless at a time
like this and similarly insults the
other two for even talking about it
and yet after luffy says fair enough you
two are the scrubs then
they all remain and get hit by the
fireballs again take note of the fact
that on paper
the other two talk like they're not
going to follow luffy's orders but luffy
decided the criteria for the game
and they ended up following it this is a
microcosm of why luffy is destined to
become the pirate king and not the other
two
since despite not liking it and not
being willing to admit it
they do often follow his lead it's
hilarious to see
zorro getting angry asking them what in
the world are they doing
you gotta respect them although it is
stupid that they are messing around
in the face of two yonko clearly none of
them are that intimidated
if they have the time to mess around
like that kaido tells big mom to stand
back
and she comments that he's playing with
his food again i think in kaido's mind
he is more sure of himself taking on big
mom
than he is taking on those five
characters he thought of when he looked
at luffy that's why big mom wasn't one
of them
and probably why he feels comfortable
teaming up with her since he thinks
he can take care of her later here he's
clearly okay with giving orders to big
mom
and big mom actually goes with it for a
while keep in mind she said luffy was
hers before
but clearly kaido's been getting more
chances to fight with him here
zoro recognized killer as the man slayer
and of course zoro beat him in the past
zorro puts his bandana on so you know
things are getting serious
it's funny here because these two have a
similar rivalry as kit and luffy and
killer says that he would have beaten
zorro
if he had his punishers back then
meaning his weapons of choice
zoro retorts it would have ended the
same regardless and i for one
obviously think killer isn't on zorro's
level but i
like that at least killer acts
competitive i'm enjoying the rivalries
even as they fight on the same side
both these supernova take shots at kaido
and i've been saying that i think zoro
is gonna cut
kaido but this is not that moment there
are pressure marks left on kaido's neck
but it didn't break the skin
and kaido isn't surprised he expected as
much from these two
these are definitely not odin cuts yet
nevertheless the odin comparison is very
significant here
zoro says to himself that he needs to
release more of enma's power
and enema was wielded by none other than
odin and was one of the weapons he used
to injure kaido
this blade will no doubt play a part in
his eventual defeat enma is a reference
to a god who presides over hell
this god is the personification of death
like the shinigami
we know how big mythology is for oda who
used mythology as the inspiration for
kaido's gyarados devil fruit
is it not fitting then for odin's blade
and a blade that mythologically
represents
death to play a role in beating or maybe
killing a seemingly invincible mythical
creature the symbolism is too heavy to
pass up in my opinion and zorro is
clearly not shaken here and he will as
he says release more of enemas power
that is inevitable however for now we
jump back to the supernova captains and
luffy is overconfident as usual here
saying he'll settle this fight in an
instant we get a great moment where all
three supernova captains prepare to
attack kaido
together in a combo chain kaido smiles
and welcomes them to bring it on
he calls the brats little monsters which
is a sign of respect but
patronizing at the same time as if they
can't compete with the big or real
monsters like kaido
they all take different approaches luffy
his straightforward one that already
hurt kaido
kid will try crushing him with that
makeshift mecha of his and law says
he'll take him apart from within
probably the most interesting strategy
kaido then gets hit by luffy with a kong
gun an attack that could punch around
king kong himself
kid then uses punk vice to seemingly
crush the yonko
and law uses tac to drop large boulders
on him this epic combo from out of our
fanboy dreams
does not do much though big mom laughs
and then kaido laughs and comes out in
his dragon form i'm not sure why he'd
switch to this form and we'll see how he
plans to fight with it next chapter but
not gonna lie i kind of wanted him to
stay in his humanoid form
what the transformation is good for
though is creating an
epic panel where our guys on the bottom
of the panel are completely overwhelmed
visually
by kaido and big mom towering over them
and taking a large portion
of the upper half of the panel the panel
shows us what our supernova
are seeing from their perspectives and
symbolically shows how difficult the
task they are attempting to undertake
will be
this literally looks like humans
associated with earth attempting to
challenge
the gods associated with the skies or
heavens kaido then says it's a shame he
has to kill them but it can't be helped
he's no longer trying to make them his
subordinates he now 100
plans to kill them and what's more to
take everything they have
including their friends treasure
poneglyphs and so on as
kaido says the victor of this battle
will take a massive step towards
becoming the pirate king
and we're told this is an inevitable
clash as we
see a close-up of kaido and then luffy
clearly they are the centerpieces of
this
intense battle i don't have to tell you
how crazy or hyped this
is it's so awesome to see kaido finally
taking them seriously
even saying the victor of this battle
rather than saying i'll take a massive
step to become the pirate king and we
know that luffy beating a yonko
will be an insanely massive leap towards
becoming pirate king but the fact that
even a yonko feels that beating him will
get the yonko
massively closer shows how much respect
luffy has earned
and how far he has come the inevitable
clash comment
is a nice addition too because not
everyone can be the pirate king and
since everyone wants it eventually you
have to clash with others who also want
it until one remains
they are all trying to turn their dream
into a reality the only question is who
will manifest their will into the world
who has the most powerful will the most
unwavering commitment
although you could argue that will can't
overcome the gap in natural talent and
strength one piece has shown time and
time again
that those with the strongest will find
a way to make the impossible possible
as they go even if they don't know how
they'll get there
they trust in themselves that they'll
figure it out if they don't give up and
keep moving forward
luffy's story is beyond inspirational
and as i mentioned
even though these chapters are good in
and of themselves they are leading to
better and more intense ones as we move
forward which is a good thing because
now that kaido messed around with them a
bit we can expect to see
more serious fighting moving forward and
let's appreciate that this whole chapter
followed the insanely intense and epic
happenings
on the roof moving forward these guys
are probably going to be
sharing chapters with the non-main
battles taking place which is cool
they're all going to be interesting in
their own right i'm sure of that
but we all know this is the main event
we've been dying to see
but yeah i had more to say about this
chapter than i thought i would
so thank you to everyone who stay tuned
until the very end if you did enjoy and
want to keep the one piece reviews
coming the best thing you could do is
smash that like button like a true
pirate king if you haven't be sure to
join the nakama by subscribing and this
is crucial hit that notification bell or
else you will miss
future chapter reviews it appears there
will be a break next week but never fear
while you wait for the next intense
chapter to drop feel free to check out
my growing one piece playlist where i
got
videos about the yonko warlords
supernova
and other truly epic topics link to that
playlist is in the description
and i especially want to thank the
patron squad over on patreon
and here on youtube who helped make
videos like this one possible first
and foremost i want to thank the patron
of legend the one acknowledged by lord
tuigo himself
and the most donated champion of the
world alpha sigma and
are the one tier patrons the ones who
stand atop all clans ingrata the world
acquire respect but they have a
heparithian emperor otaku spidey life
tinel fake buddhist and tungsten tarkis
and our pro hero tier patrons the one
and only gilgamesh steelers angel crews
anatoly kazowski joel stanton very gucci
jessica kayla fond ruthu and aura alicia
actor
bonnie parks hinokami and water the
red-haired raven florian
joanne garcia jack watches anime fat boy
games deadly saint matthew cruz anthony
schreiber
hi jinx and mr waffles thank you all so
much
if you do enjoy our work you can support
more of it by going over to patreon.com
anime uproar and becoming a patron today
for as little as one dollar
if you do so you'll get your name
featured in future videos alongside
these amazing people right here and
you'll even get access to our private
patron only discord where we talk about
anime
life and of course thank memes so check
out patreon.com anime upload link in the
description if you're interested you can
also join the youtube channel by
clicking that blue join button next to
the subscribe button that you've
hopefully already destroyed
so yeah you can support more content
that way if you prefer whichever way you
choose to support us you can get the
same great benefits
thanks again and until next time see ya
space cowboys
[Music]
me